bello sarebbe se io sono rino e oggi a
grandissima richiesta nuova challenge
slime colori challenge che decidono i
prossimi colori perché io vi ho messo un
sondaggio e vi ho chiesto come volete
che si di spruzzi di colore a maggior
parte di voi mi ha votato rosso contro
potete vedere qua abbiamo tantissimi
ingredienti di rossi con i socialisti
gli ingredienti arancioni io sono timbro
rosso e vitale timba renzo si sarà
capito siamo tutti a maggiore a tutto
rosso previsto di altro che che
balotelli dopo questo abbiamo fatto rosa
contro sarebbe e abbiamo fatto viola
contro giallo questo challenge
noi andremo a bendarci a pescare un
ingrediente alla volta e alla fine del
video vincerà chi non sa in più rosso
nel mio caso aiazzone questo caso ma
attenzione altri che questi ingredienti
potrebbero non essere rossi dentro
perché alcuni stabili sapete la
confezione di un colore ma poi c'è un
altro colore buffa vede potrebbero
essere bianchi o di altri colori
rovinare lo slime quindi dobbiamo
riuscire a essere fortunata in pescare
solo i colori del nostro team passate un
bel mi piace se questo video raggiunge
il 15 mila mi piace andremo a fare
un'altra challenge sla il colore e
decidete voi scrivete nei commenti il
quale volete che siano i colori della
prossima sciences line colori ma scorso
video raggiunto i 17 di lana
grazie a 15.000 sembra utilizzare una
challenge alla fine del video come
sempre dovrete portare quale sondaggio
se vinco i nostri pc ficcare in base
alla bellezza del nose live pallonari e
bellezza nella loro camera ma come
potete vedere è vitale alla felpa è in
una maglietta corta perché c'è
caldissimo ma lui non aveva niente di
arancione quindi ho dovuto mettere la
felpa poi di vita realistica vediamo
quanto originare si digeriscono bastasin
mese nei ricoveri patatine foto andarci
io la mia bellissima benda diminu vitale
ha mal essi casta a tratti ha mestiere
problema scala ora via al contesi molto
piccolo in questa è una confezione di
shampoo ti portiamo un tubetto di flickr
rossi to remove nell'usato arancione che
potrebbe essere di un altro colore
livorno molto curioso di vedere perché
belli sono spenti ed aver avanzare di un
altro colore
secondo me bianco scriviamo andiamo
subito a vedere se glitter rospi per
fortuna ma forse una specie di colla
trasparente con i glitter rossi che
fortuna ho subito pescato e rossa altri
google
vi diamo resto diventa lo rotto come
l'effetto che bello ad ora sta un po
sparendo si vedono solo i glitter 8
marzo l'inter
vediamo invece il tuo di che colore è
uno districante istantaneo quindi
lasciamo capitano chiamanti non ci posso
crederci e prova pure benissimo mettendo
un pò giallo tè caldo torna pronti per
pescare preso la mia
ciao più presa su qualcosa che mi
fermerà molto non gliela venda giovane e
pennisi ha sicuramente allora che non lo
divenne parole sempre tempere temperate
invece ho preso un ultra dolce bambini
shampoo che la bottiglietta e
trasparenti quindi vedo già anche il
rosso ma non è molto rose rosse un po
penso bene infatti e trasparente
ora vediamo di che colore farà il nostro
slam ma non penso che coloreranno il mio
sliven funzionato di aprire questo
cellulare con la natura tutta la zona è
bello sicuramente vita e va in vantaggio
ora i fatti
ecco quel mio shampoo ultra dolce viene
bruciato sono una bottiglietta che la
rotta e trasparente
ma diventerà mai rottami udrih fragilità
ma almeno profuma bene ma sono proprio
in svantaggio ha detto romani ciliegia
vinciamo sto mischiando bene bere la
tempera e adesso la apriamo senza
fregata quasi troppo liquido fare altro
che mi sa che è a bordo risulta
anch'esso parte chissà come sarà una
volta attivo sarà bellissimo saranno
rovigo
ebbene sì vitale in vantaggio scrivete
ora nei commenti qual è il vostro colore
preferito fra rosso e arancione pesche
rosso io preferisco anche arancino però
farebbe bene a mangiare
allora prossimo giorno 3 mag ap la scusa
che ha pescato un palloncino o un
talloncino che cosa c'è dentro il
pallone io penso che non ci sia niente
dentro il palloncino e quelli aggiungerò
aggiungono signori io invece ho pescato
o no ma è nuovamente una donna liberata
che devo dire che questo palloncino ti
somiglia tutto benissimo
in fondo e tondo come vitale e sempre
pronto a un'altra colla glitter speriamo
che questa abbia un po di colorante dei
altrimenti non lo conosce raber niente
miscela tra un po di timore colore
colore un pochino lo sta colorando e
fino adesso sembra fragola aspetto
momento rosa o no perché il rosso
diluito con il bianco diventa rosa per
de rocco e facciale un gesto non diventa
rosso che c'è qualcosa non faccio niente
o povera palloncino
vecchie dopo il vantaggio che così si no
mi piacciono troppo caldo e di non sei
più team arancione paradigma vi ho detto
variamo caos
speriamo che ti porti sfortuna questo
piano che ti possa diventare lì lo slime
arancione tutto solo invidioso perché il
mio più bello vediamo ora cosa vediamo
bene dalla forma devo dire che io ho
pescato una bottiglietta di qualcosa
spero che sia un colorante mi sa che ho
capito bene che contestava ma ci fanno
credere tute importunate questo
che sfortuna un po che volevo anche
bellissimo perché metallizzato emesso
prestato dei glitter e non me ne faccio
niente perché non cambieranno il colore
dello stato si distorce beschi vuote
perché con la svizzera in creta con la
colla ed ecco qua il mio bottiglione
enorme di glitter e che insomma non mi
servono molto però vediamo magari un po
di colore lo daranno allo slide mancino
[Risate]
vediamo un po forse lo stanno colorando
un po
sembrerò tavana già secondo portami tu
che portò grassi e di crescere ancora
tanto
[Musica]
l'arancione dentro la ragione carissimo
chi è questo per liquido però quello
prossimo e malizioso allora attivo anche
il comitato ifi c'era anche dice
l'attrice va detta non è ancora arrivata
dalla fine potrei anche recuperare con
il mio si è poi anche recuperare da
quanto è bello il mio
reggerà il paragone il tuo rosso tra di
trento è una vera non mi dire che ho
preso un altro shabunda formate per
propriano zampa nessun formule tipo di
glitter queste clip sono nuovi non li
avevo mai visti prima suo tifo scaglie
di clijsters
solo chi ritorna scagliano splendidi
glitter e questo shampoo
non penso proprio che sarà veramente
però quello su arancione quindi potrebbe
essere rosa per fortuna genoma sparagna
e scritto basso potremmo quasi
sicuramente bianca vediamo dopo aver
scoprirlo di scoprire soprattutto chi
vincerà chi pensava che ricevevano rosso
rosso grosso viaggio gianfranco nappi
per l'aria sfortuna ora voi vite con me
rosso rosso rosa rosso
l'italiana è ora come diventa tra
l'altro penso di non avermi mai messo il
balsamo nella colla non so che effetto
farà la m morto oppure si scioglie e
perché oggi sono fortunatissimo polvere
di stelle si sia mai altre cose per bene
eppure sberluccicante con questa inter è
stato qualcosa di molto grande e abbiamo
preso qualcosa di molto piccolo spero
che non sia il solito cha un po perché
non far rumore
sembra un po ma vediamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
certo la cosa pure metallizzato
grandissimo è il decreto non so se mi
sembra sono dei pigmenti arancioni un po
scuri però quindi potrebbero cambiare il
colore scuro
speriamo che cammina come ho detto ok
ecco alcune però come dovrei di vedere
come diventa penso che questo bel
pancione mattina rotta perché carrozzone
forse perché grosso molto forte ma non
può diventare ha ragione ma pergola
charlie guarda che è arancione scuro ma
insomma la bottiglia rotta
[Musica]
ma l'unico modo per salvarmi e pescare
un altro colorante molte più scura di
questo altrimenti rimarrà arancione mia
non sarà mai rosso vi diremo del gioco
che si trasforma critica ma questo mi
rovino lo slancio colore cambia colore
oro bellissimo scomparendo e rischio di
rompere nella speriamo bene che
accompagna questa cosa bruttissimo
realtà rimane fortissima ma di colore è
talmente forte che si è fortunati ad
atene anche questo è diventato un color
papaya conto di semi di papaya guarda in
un insieme di papaya o paghiamo i semi
lo chiamo questo slam ma allora questo è
il primo ultimo torna quindi abbiamo
fatto anni per salvarsi io voglio dire
va bene che sembrano da montati sembrano
quasi per tutti e due l'addio più bello
è più bello vedremo se lo rovinerà i
test ma è anche lavoro il tuo tentativo
di distruggere la terra è andato a buon
fine
perché perché questi ai mattoni di
un'altra cosa non è bellissimo e provo
sentire l'odore prima di avere allora
vediamo stati pescaccia di niente non sa
di niente
vediamo è uno show per bambini
all'albicocca albicocche regione di
cotone e perché non controversa
effettivamente altre cose che compro
come un bocchetta invece una crema mani
quindi non penso proprio che milioni è
rotta
io non sono sicuro che questa sia di
colore arancione forse trasparenti come
quello che avevo katrina è male ma gli è
andata male nuovamente perché una crema
mani e non penso proprio che siano mi è
costato solida ma è proprio letta questa
crema mani che sembrava
per questa ragione brutta ma è rimasta
solida questa crema
vediamo quello di vitale e trasparente
da parente
[Musica]
vabbè magari sarà un po lucido di raitre
non è vero magari non la prenderà solo
un pochettino è più lucida curante che
può olio a si è più lucido guardate che
bella sono stato fortunato
no non è vero vediamo se riusciamo a
salvare il nostro slime è rovinato per
sempre pronti a reggio
ho preso molto liquida questa cosa non
mi dire che a quanto sembra molto rumore
di glitter vediamo tutto però sembra
quasi viola ho preso dalle paillettes
arancioni che faranno da tumore sente
fortunato sceglie ogr ed a trasformarmi
in rosso fino al business
non lo so ecco qua secondo me circolare
questo sembrato giusto speriamo che lo
trasformi in rosso magari diventa
marrone slalom in scadenza
riteniamo non si capisce
vediamone schiavo lo so proprio la
diventerà questa ragione pian piano lo
sai che ti carica su quel rosso sempre
più accesa è ancora un arancione seconda
aspettano e mezzo ancora vediamo vediamo
perché non come si debba muffa abbiamo
fatto diventare rosso farla diventare no
no forse sta diventando un pochino più
grassi sento proprio con lo smalto non è
un po più razzo che praticare la
prossima bellissimo si viva un po te
pulito come si aprono le fornirà ragioni
sarà bagnetto non sono per river the
sick rose bello perché saranno
supertruccate tanti tanti rumor etti
dopo quando sarà attivo
ma che siamo pronti per attivare il
nostro sla e ben 32
ecco qua il mood laimer sodico rossiccio
perché non è proprio un super 8 è una
specie di rosso aranciato e morbidi che
attendibile grazie a tutto quello stato
che ho messo neanche crema mani un po di
tutto quindi come il colore secondo voi
è più in rosso o le più arancione
scrivete nei commenti e aree andiamo
assieme a sentire un po di sony smr si
vedono un po i glitter ed è molto
vediamo ora proprio di vitale arancione
si presenta uno slide vincitore di me
capita perché hanno stai il vincitore
perché finalmente mi pare dopo tutto
questo tempo è riuscito a fare lo slide
set
vienna e bellissimo guardano anche core
è attivata su per bere tra l'altro non
si è indurito con otto quintali di
bicarbonato schioppettante direi che può
king da paura
e poi fa tutte le bollicine e pupo pure
perso pezzo pezzo è la super estendibile
super arancio nissimo questa volta lisa
che al bureau va affatto uno slide
bellissima e super arancione
[Musica]
che ne pensate voi mi piace prende
chiedendo le perline di vetro cadendo
perché farà un po pc cosette vediamoli
affianchi la mafia ma sono tutti e due
bellissime giocata però è più fragoroso
perché tutti i pettini neri mi piace
tanto
l'inter nazareth la notte immuni adesso
vediamo le mani come mai tutte le mani
così ros
mettere già quella sciarpa battente
rossi nota di colore a tempera nido
sì ma allora perché tu non ce le ragioni
ci aiutate da per vitale che ha fatto lo
slideshow bello da abbozzate chi picchia
cercando a voi si ingrassa portate
quanto dati il servizio di brosso team
gresini commetti che altri colori volete
che possiamo più aspettare le prime
colori challenge e ora vi lasciamo a
quattro cartellini a supplicare per
vedere i nostri altri
[Musica]
nel cielo la terra lontana
no perché
a chiederlo
[Musica]
arrivare